$110,000 goes the financial system
$30,000 to the worker he takes all of
the risk puts in all of the money Wall
Street takes none of the risk puts in
none of the money and gets most of it
they get the Lion Share that's where the
money goes It goes in the pockets of
Wall Street risk in my view is more a
function of the investor than the
investment people say what do you think
about gold I'll say well how much you
know about gold what do you about real
estate well how much do you know about
real estate I love entrepreneurship and
I love the stock market actually for
people that understand it right the
problem with the stock market is not
investing in stocks it's investing in
stocks with no education but when you
can surround yourself with great people
and great advisors and great teachers
having a simple bookkeeper is not that
expensive to have on your team and to
help you with your discipline and money
revealed is an exclusive video series
where self-made millionaires share their
secrets on how they got rich in this
episode you'll learn how to make smart
Investments destroy the limited beliefs
that hold you back and retire without
going broke these are the lessons that
they don't teach you in school about
making money and we partnered with the
series Creator Jeff Hayes to bring it to
you on my YouTube channel
enjoy don't invest another penny in your
401k until you watch this next interview
with Andy Tanner I was riveted again
very contrarian in his attitudes and I'm
not here to give you the financial
advice but I am here to tell you that
you need to listen to what this guy has
to say before you move forward with
those types of retirement accounts
there's a wealth of information here his
energy again is something that's going
to stimulate you into thinking and
taking action enjoy my interview with
Andy Tanner well Andy I'm excited to
have this conversation because you have
a a reputation for having a lot of
passion around on the subject of
investing so for sure yes so I'm looking
forward so thanks for taking the time oh
thanks for having me I'm excited about
this so how did you end up in this
career that you're in like what was your
trajectory well I I started out like
most people uh went to school and uh I I
didn't go to school for any particular
uh major I was I'm 68 so they uh they
hired me to play basketball I was going
to say did you have a basketball
scholarship 6'8 I feel like a very small
person sitting next to you I tell people
I couldn't shoot I couldn't jump but I
could foul so
they found a spot for me there and when
when that was over I just got in the
workforce like anybody else I uh I uh I
struggled to find what I want to do so
my wife and I were in very low-paying
jobs and what was interesting is in in
uh the year 2000 when the market fell uh
we had small 401ks we were just getting
started but they were really you know
they were drastically hit and I was
puzzled cuz I felt like we were taking
the advice that uh everyone was telling
us to take and I thought boy if this
happens again you know this and I I
started to
research and the more I researched the
the less impressed I was right and I I
got angry actually and I thought you
know people need to know this and so
through that research it channeled me
into being an educator and a speaker and
so now for the past 25 years uh we've
had the opportunity to travel the world
and uh as a student and a teacher to
share the things I've been learning with
others and it's been amazing so what did
you discover about 401k what should
people know well you get me going on
this it's uh very passionate to really
understand both sides of the 401K coin
it's important to know the narrative in
the history yeah I don't know that
there's anything financially that more
people are involved in that they have
less knowledge about than uh plans like
the
401K and so uh the first thing I would
say is that there was never a think tank
or Brain Trust of smart women and smart
men that got together and said hey how
can a middle- inome worker really set
themselves up well for retirement let's
build a plan that never happened to
understand retirement uh let's go back
to the beginning let's go back to where
retirement began uh there was a company
called uh American Express and they
weren't always about credit cards they
were a courier you know like UPS or
Federal Express and in the late 1800s
they said let's have a pension let's
let's get people in and we'll we'll uh
pay them while they work and if they
work for us for many many years we'll
continue to pay them and uh you'll never
be rich you'll never be prosperous but
you'll survive and and we'll give you a
little pension and that was where the
first pension was really born wow some
people want to be an entrepreneur some
people want to be investors and really
try to to to prosper other people just
want survival and this idea of a pension
that you'd never be rich but boy it
would help you survive it really changed
the American dream for a lot of people
and gave a sense of security I imagine
yeah you know we'll make that trade some
of us the going for the freedom instead
of taking the security that's a that's a
popular trade and it changed education
because think about it you know our
great grandparents After High School if
they went uh you could go work on the
farm you could go on the military you go
work force maybe you go to college but
with more and more companies saying hey
we'll take care of you we'll give you a
pension we'll we'll take care of you we
going to college and learning to work at
a job became really you know you go to
the job fair and there's really two
types of people some people are scared
of losing their job some people are
scared of having one right and so it was
so people would say hey here's the
program go to school get good grades go
to go to the college land a job work
there for for many many years and get a
pension well in the 60s you might
remember if if you if you're history
buff at all or car buff is there was a a
company called The studa Baker company
and they had these cars and they had a
union and workers well they fell on
tough times people weren't buying studa
Bakers and when you looked at that
company's finances they couldn't pay
their workers they were going to go
bankrupt and he had all these workers
saying what's going to happen to my
pension right and so that was kind of
the beginning of the end of Pensions um
that we've we've seen happen and they
went to President Kennedy and said hey
what can you do for us he said ask not
what your country can do for
you but in reality he said okay we'll
see what we can do and he he established
a commission to study this problem of
companies that were not funding their
pensions properly that that put the
worker at risk of of not being able to
uh to retire well he unfortunately he
was assassinated and president Johns
didn't do much and Watergate took over
Nixon but in 1974 almost a hundred years
since that first American Express
pension uh they signed something called
Arisa MH and orisa was a legislative
idea to bring these businesses up to
Snuff to say look you're going to have
to take care of not only the the worker
but the spouse you're going to have to
prove to us that you're allocating funds
properly and the regulations just
businesses hated these handcuffs they
hated these regulations and so it
created a greater enmity between
business and the worker and all of this
set the stage for uh for the 41k
when did the 401K come into existence
well it came into existence in in the
fall of
1978 so Arisa the employee retirement
income Security Act was in 1974 under
President Ford and President Jimmy
Carter was trying to push some
legislation he was worried about you
know the three Martini lunch that we
would deduct from our taxes and and and
so uh in 1978 there was a huge fight
over over Taxation and how this is going
to work work and a person really wants
to understand how this stuff works is
President Carter will say here are my
ideas and then Congress will push back
say no here are our ideas and you you
established bipartisan commissions to
say let's see what we can do and so
there was a Senator he was from New York
and he became later congressman and his
name was Barbara connal MH and uh he had
uh some constituents two lobbyists from
Kodak and from Xerox and they had
noticed that in the 60s there had been a
provision for Rich Bankers to take
profit sharing bonuses and pack them
away and this is important because a
rich executive right they don't need
this money it's extra cash and so
they're to them it's a tax problem well
Xerox and craft said hey we want the
same thing for our exec so they got in
this senate or in this congressman's ear
and he said well let's just put into
this little paragraph and a young
attorney uh rich Richard Stranger in his
20s wrote less than a thousand words and
they slipped this into legislation under
what was called section 401K of the uh
of the tax code right of the US and what
it did is it said we'll open this
provision for uh for other companies and
when unnoticed mostly it's tiny under I
mean part of under a thousand words you
know in the tax code and in
1980 the world changed there was a
consult
uh he's a wonderful man his name is Ted
benna M and Ted benna was uh was a
pension consultant he was working with a
bank that had a tax problem and he said
hey let's see if we can uh maybe use
this 401K statute to help your Rich
Executives uh get these bonuses we'll
change how it works we'll make it
pre-tax which will save the company
money and uh and he pitched it to them
and they had a huge problem and this is
really really where the story really
goes into a new chapter you got to sell
this to a bank teller MH and if a bank
teller is going to foro their Christmas
bonus for tax purposes that might save
them you know $40 $50 that's not
exciting where Rick's executive you know
it's thousands of dollars right so you
had a disparity Y and so how do you get
a bank teller to say yeah I'll
participate and Ted said what if you
gave them an employee match what if you
and it was literally bait literal bait
to say how can we convince these people
to participate and uh they went to the
bank they said boy this would work great
but they didn't want to be the guinea
pig so they said no okay and so Ted said
well I'll start it my own company and on
January 1st of 1981 the very first
401K program for retirement for
employees was set up and it caught on
like wildfire the important thing to
notice that at no time uh was someone
worried about this worker they were
worried about SA saving money for Main
Street for the business and so that was
the first chapter well as this took off
you can imagine what W Street saw m uh
if you're a mutual fund salesman you say
my gosh people are going to be put on
autopilot before they even get their
paycheck they're going to buy my
products right I don't tell people to
get in or out of
401ks uh but I would suggest that every
person look at both sides of the coin
what do I get out of it what do the
people helping me do this get out of it
and the mutual fund industry changed
forever uh as of today we have about
$7.5 trillion dollar now wow collected
in these mutual funds and these defined
contribution plans W and if there's one
point I would communicate and beg and
plead people to understand would be this
a pension is income isn't it mhm you
collect income
and you pay expenses and you collect
income and pay expenses and that pension
would last for life you would receive
that money until you died right and so
in financial education land we call that
a cash flow-based idea that that a
pension was a function of your cash flow
it was a function of your income the
moment that Ted benna made that switch
for his first company it stopped being a
function of cash flow and it became a
function of your balance sheet your net
worth M now think about that for a
minute bills happen every month until
you die and so as long as that money is
coming every month that liability is on
your company they have to figure out how
to send that check out every month right
but the moment they switched to where
you contribute right now it became a
function of your net worth became a
function of the balance sheet rather
than the income statement that's a huge
difference because now there's an
hourglass of time and you have to look
at that balance you have to say hm well
that last me 20 years you never had to
make that decision under pension and now
people who were educated to get
jobs now are forced to invest they're
forced to learn about mutual funds or
stocks or bonds or paper assets with no
training so basically what you're saying
is the 401K supplanted the um the
pension so people say we're doing away
with pensions and then the employees are
just going to contribute and that sits
on the balance sheet of the corporation
supplanted is a kind word it killed them
it killed absolutely killed them why
well if you're a business your your your
employees your liability to you they sit
on your liability colum they they're a
promise you've made and you have to deal
with that by giving them that bait of
that match saying here's this little
match I I'll give it to you when they
snatch that up they now wash their hands
of that responsibility and now worker
who drives a truck or works on assembly
line or is an isn't an accountant
attorney or an investor now has to
shoulder the burden of retirement this
was supposed to be a tiny little tax Cod
for to say is that the consideration for
the formation of it was was a way to get
taxfree income to high PA highly paid
Executives it was to recruit better
Talent if it was going to be something
that was going to be more pervasive and
and and wage earners were going to start
utilizing it I'd imagine they would have
written it a bit differently imagine
that you know I'm putting money into
something every month called a 401k that
was never designed to do what it's doing
if you were to to use the phrase the law
of unintended consequences there is not
a better case on planet Earth uh of that
law than than the 401K well the next
chapter of this is Wall Street yeah the
most important word or phrase on Wall
Street is assets under management right
that's how they make their money it's
fees right the larger amount of money
they can collect the more money they
make and so that's a that's a rough
thing when all of a sudden you can just
hear the champagne corks popping when
they said my gosh we're going to take
money out of their paycheck before they
even see it right and they're going to
buy our products and we'll have those
assets under management the thing that's
scary about this is is investors you and
I would if you were real State investor
you'd look at a property and look at its
merits before you'd invest or you look
at a business and look at its merits you
would never be on autopilot just blindly
buying things because you on schedule to
do so regardless of the price regardless
of of the economy regardless of where
it's going but the mutual fund money PE
people know dollar cost averaging means
this send me your money when the market
goes up send me your money when the
market goes down send me your money when
the market goes sideways in other words
no matter what happens send me your
money right how much risk do they take
yeah oh they take none they take none
know they're getting a piece of all
those dollars every month and so when
you look at their profit that's an
infinite return because they have no
money in the deal of their own right so
they have an infinite rate of return and
absolutely no risk and a lack of
responsibility many respects too right
cuz if they perform poorly and the
market Goes Down based on how they're
behaving the person who gets hurt is the
person who worked for the money they
still get their fees if you go to these
many managers and you say my balance is
small who will they blame you're not
saving enough you should give us more
money right they will blame you every
single time you're not saving enough
it's your fault people are not saving
and that has been the banner they have
enacted Le the next legislation was 2006
under President Bush where they said
where they said hey we need the pension
protection act which really doesn't
protect pens it protects Define
contributions and they said look we're
going to make this automatic enrollment
see before then you had to go into your
human resource department say hey I
volunteer I'd like to participate now
you have to opt out rather than opt in
and so imagine if you're just look at
the other side of the coin if you're a
mutual fund salesman you get to have a
product where people buy an autopilot if
they have a job and they have to opt out
from buying your product rather than opt
in in this whole narrative there is not
one instance where anyone had the
interest of a middle inome or low income
worker in mind ever it was either the
rich executive wanting to defer a big
bonus or it was a company trying to help
their bottom line or is the mutual fund
industry imagine $7 trillion under
management whether it goes up down or
sideways that's a lot of fees they get
to take yeah I've had the opportunity to
talk with Ted Bena personally he's a
wonderful man he's a gentleman and he's
often asked if he feels if this is a
failure he says well Andy number one how
can you say it's a failure if it was
never intended to shoulder the burden of
retirement number one and number two
we've helped people save $7 trillion
well you can look at that a couple ways
you've also helped Wall Street
accumulate $7 trillion which is their
engine to make them money and the tough
thing and the thing that makes me so
passionate about this is the worker you
know I I I knew we were going to have a
chance to chat today and so I took the
liberty of uh of printing out a report
uh from Vanguard this is called how
America saves 2018 it's vanc car's
defined defined contribution plan data
of the $7.5 trillion dollar that are in
these plans uh vanard vanard has more
than 1.2 trillion of it wow so this is
an excellent sampling of of where they
are and and it's interesting because if
you look at a age there's two numbers
that we ought to discuss the the first
one is if you look at people 45 to 54
mhm and they're staring at retirement
the average 40K balance in Vanguard for
this age group is just under
$130,000 now that might sound exciting
it's six figures that's got to last 20
years of retirement but more important
than the average because if you have a
few millionaires at the top that drags
that up more more important the average
would be the median yeah what does the
median mean well that's the guy in the
middle right in the middle that means
half everyone is above half everyone's
below the medium is
70,000 now if you plan on on having a
20e retirement that's $300 a month yeah
so while Ted might say well how can you
c a failure if we've helped people save
trillion well for these people it's a
failure and these are the people I care
about imagine that half the participants
of this age if you go to to 55 to 64
that's $71,000 in the mean MH that's
people people that are 65 and over
$64,000 goes down as they're getting
older 64 well they're not able to put
money in anymore and so this is at a
time where we have a stock market at
all-time highs yeah so here's the
question where' the money go if the
stock market is alltime highs and I'm
looking at these types of balances you
took the words for my mouth I mean
average R return all those years they've
been in it why is where where did the
money go don't take my word for this
please I admonish people study it for
yourself right the person who founded
Vanguard is a man named John Bogle he's
written many books he's a great uh
proponent of the small investor in fact
he actually left the company he started
which was Vanguard uh he actually
started as a as a MBA thesis I believe
and said I'm going to go do this but he
left the company he's become somewhat of
an advocate and the way he teaches this
is something every investor should
investigate for themselves in my humble
opinion it's called The Law of
compounding costs and the way he states
it is he gives an example uh that I site
often of a worker who's say uh 20 years
old M and they look at an Actuarial
Table and say okay he's going to die at
85 so the the mutual fund company's
going to say all right that's 65 years
of investing we can get his money how do
we do this let's say they take uh he
starts with $1,000 and doesn't add to it
just thousand bucks and he throws in the
stock market and he gets maybe 8% a year
well the power of compounding is
something else and that is over over 65
years that's going to wind up a little
over
$140,000 That's The Power of compounding
the problem is is that's if he gets the
8% now that's what they're getting
behind the curtain it's growing at 8%
but if they take fees let's say they
take 2% 2 and a
half% that means that on his statement
even though the money is actually
compounding at 8 he's compound
compounding at 5.5 and in that same time
period he won't have 140 Grand he'll
have 30 wow makes that big a difference
$110,000 goes to the financial system
$30,000 to the worker he takes all of
the risk puts in all of the money Wall
Street takes none of the risk puts in
none of the money it gets m they get the
Lion Share that's where the money goes
It goes in the pockets of Wall Street so
first that's startling yeah you know
that you know the 2 and a half% that's
taken translates into the Lion Share
over time of of The
Upside but most people the attitude is
well why would I go in for well I'm
putting money in taxfree they're still
going to pay tax at some point but the
the fees become another form of tax
what's what's interesting is the fees
they've gotten better as competition's
gotten better but when people work the
numbers they'll still see that the line
share go and it's silent you know it's
interesting if I were to ask you how
much you pay for your phone bill you
could show me right if I say what do you
pay for healthcare you'd say well here's
a aspirin for $75 at the hospital and
here's how much my insurance will cover
if you go get a massage at the end they
say this is your ticket right but when
you ask people what they pay for
financial advice no one can tell you
that number wow it's that stealth and
yet it's something we do every month
every single paycheck they cannot tell
you what they pay for financial they can
tell you the price is right what a
gallon of gas is what a carton of milk
is they cannot tell you what they pay
for financial you know it's kind of like
well if if I put money in the bank I
just watch the balance the bank balance
that's what they feel like they're doing
they're just watching a bank balance not
understanding the Dynamics that are
going on around their money I'm glad you
brought up a bank balance because this
is one of the bigger lies I feel they
sell most of this legislation is passed
in the name of us not saving enough
money not saving enough money as a
matter of fact even some of the reports
recall this is call this as savings
nothing could be further from the truth
there is such a large difference between
investment and Savings in terms of the
way it works and the risks involved it's
night and day for example if I save
money I put in what's called a deposit I
take some money I hand it to the bank
they go put it on the shelf and lend it
out to people but when I buy a mutual
fund they're buying stock
I'm a purchaser of an equity I'm a
purchaser I'm in the equities market now
most likely or the debt market and so
there's a much it's much different than
having cash and having an inventory
because think about this in a savings
account you earn interest minuscule as
it might be you're still earning
interest but in a mutual fund you're
paying fees yeah you're paying if you
want that money and this is important if
you want that money out you simply go
make a withdra raw I would like my money
back please but if you want to liquidate
uh Investments you have to have someone
someone to buy right what you're
offering it's entirely different than
savings so think about this I have a
saying that if you want to see the
future and have a crystal ball policy
and demographics gives us the future so
you bring up a great point with savings
and investing because think about this
one of the provisions in the 401K and
and pretty much all across the board in
retirement plans is the government wants
that tax eventually right and they need
it believe me they need that Revenue one
of the things they weren't counting on
was the massive participation in this
and the falling tax revenue they weren't
ready for that that's why in the Reagan
years they tried to kill it they tried
to say we're losing all our tax revenue
so they had to build in a point where
they would pay taxes now think about
this for a moment many people are angry
with Obamacare because they're mandating
their they're making you do something
making you spend money whether you want
to or not right you should be able to
choose whether you want to do something
or not what's worse than making you buy
something that you don't want how about
forcing you to sell something that you
do want so at age 70 and a half that's
the magic number you are put on what's
called a distribution schedule where you
are required notice The Cutting Edge of
the word required this is not a
suggestion or plea you are required to
liquidate those assets on a schedule in
order to pay pay those taxes now think
about this for a moment you have 79
million Baby Boomers in the United
States probably another 15 million in
Canada under the same thing when those
PE they're hitting the 60s now when they
hit the 70s when you have 79 million
people having to push the sell button at
the same time oh yeah it's going to tank
the market who do you have in mind to
buy all that stuff China going to buy it
would you if you were them no and so you
have a a a a demographic of millions and
millions of people that are going to be
forced to sell in order to pay their
taxes and then the value of that account
literally is going to can sink very
quickly you might say oh I have this
much
accumulated that's value based on
current market that's correct and that
can vacillate and that market starts to
drop that value can go way down and and
they as you said if they're defining the
period when this is going to have to get
sold wow I mean and and I imagine
there'll be a lot of opportunist coming
in the short that you to help facilitate
the whole process we don't know how it
will affect the market all we know is
that that's a lot of mandatory selling
pressure that has to happen we don't
know how it'll affect the market but
that brings up even a more important
point is if someone really wanted to
study this they said Andy what should I
study what should I learn I would study
risk I would study two types of risk the
first type of risk we would call
something you could diversify out of
I'll give you example British
Petroleum uh their stock symbols BP well
it's supposed to be British Petroleum
some people call it broken pipe because
they had you might remember they broke a
pipe in the gulf and big environmental
problem their stock was cut in half well
if you were Diversified you only had you
know a few shares you'd be okay and so
that's what they scream in the 401K
don't be a stock picker my word
diversify divers the opposite of Warren
Buffett's advice diversify diversify
diversify what will not tell you and I
challenge anyone with a 401k to ask
their financial advisor this how are you
dealing then with systemic risk now what
is that if the whole system begins to
fall if the whole system like in the the
dot boom of of uh 2000 and the bust and
then the subprime Meltdown of 08 both of
those cut the market in half so what are
you doing in a forign 4K to manage those
risks there's a correlation between risk
and control more control you have less
risk less control you have more risk no
control it's gambling right and if you
retire after one of these crashes you're
selling off so many shares at a discount
and so instead of buying at a discount
you're selling at a vast discount it can
Crush people in retirement especially if
you only have $70,000 in there in the
first place so to a large extent you're
you're relying on luck cuz nobody knows
when these Cycles exactly are going to
happen so you're hoping or you know am I
lucky or unlucky was a market up or down
when I needed to sell yeah also if the
401k account is not it's held for your
benefit it's not really your account
right it's so how does that work I see
the FBO you know by 401K it's like so if
the government needed for some reason an
emerging circumstances to grab that
money they could well I I don't know
what it would be the government but I'll
tell you you where you're ride on key is
people say well I have this amount of
money in my 41k no you don't this money
belongs to Wall Street they're the ones
that collect the fees on it they're the
ones that get to use it they're the ones
that get to invest it as they please and
as they see fit if you think they're
just sitting on this you know let's
let's think again they're collecting
fees but if you really think this is
your money try to go get it yeah if you
think this money belongs to you try to
go get it because what you'll find is is
if you want to get this before for your
592 they're going to charge you 10%
right so if you have to pay to get
something back it's obviously not yours
is it right pay 10% plus taxes plus your
taxes and taxes are an interesting thing
too because you know people will uh
they'll get after it was really funny uh
watching the elections and I'm not
political one way or the other I just
kind of sit back and shrug my shoulders
but there's always pressure on
candidates to release their taxes uh to
say how much did you pay how much did
you pay right and the reason reason many
candidates don't is because they don't
pay any taxes right they're investors
right um a guy like Mitt Romney or a guy
like Donald Trump they're not going to
release their taxes why because they
don't pay any they're investors right in
fact let's say that an investor gets
capital gains in the past which was used
to be around 15 to 20% uh rather than
the you know 40 to 60 that that doctors
and dentists can be paying if they
really count everything right well if if
I'm a doctor or a dentist and I I have
my account and I see I'm paying 4050 60%
taxes I see these investors paying 15% I
say what gives well they say look a guy
like Trump and Romney are investing
they're taking more risk than you are
and so they're going to get lower tax
rates guess what if you put money in a
4on k you're dodging ordinary income tax
MH well when you pull it out guess what
you're going to pay ordinary income tax
so you're taking investor risk but
you're not getting investor tax benefit
you're you're getting employee tax
benefit even though you're taking
investor risk well now so let's talk to
that group the engineer the doctor the
lawyer what have you the professional
that probably has been funding a 401k
their their you know their whole career
now they're 50ish uh you know on the
sheet you know that you just read and
but maybe they're in the higher
percentage of you know what they've
accumulated but they're looking saying
wow this didn't work out the way I
thought it would and uh and I'm subject
to having to you know being forced to
take this money out in the future or
maybe I even need to take some out now
um and uh it's not all there so what
kind of investing advice do you give
them you know they maybe have some money
you know so it's not like they got zero
but they don't have enough to retire and
and uh they don't want to keep working
another 20 or 30 years doing the stuff
they're doing today so what's the advice
well first of all I never tell anyone to
do with their money I always stay away
from advice because I know something and
this is very important education is more
valuable than Vice the advantage the
doctor the dentist the engineer have is
you're smart people you know in four
years years you learned how to do a root
canal that I could never learn how to do
in much much less time you can get
educated on these Investments let me say
this risk in my view is more a function
of the investor than the investment
people say what do you think about gold
they say well how much you know about
gold what do you think about real estate
well how much do you know about real
estate right my advice to those guys who
see the writing on the wall they pull
out their statement after what we've
talked about and they say you know what
but I'm not going to make it I'm going
to run this 20-year marathon and they're
going to extend that finish line out
another 20 years I'm going to be having
patience I'm going to be taking orders
I'm going to be at this desk for you
know in my 80s at this rate right what
do I do smartest thing you can do is get
educated about being an investor rather
than an employee look if you want to
make money as a dentist go to dentist
school if you want to make money as an
investor go to investor school and
there's no shortage of information to
learn how to do these things I love real
estate I love entrepreneurship and I
love the stock market actually for
people that understand it right the
problem with the stock market is not
investing in stocks it's investing in
stocks with no education right problem
in real estate isn't investing in real
estate it's investing in real estate not
knowing what you're doing so my advice
isn't to take your money out because
then you're going in the prim frying pan
in the fire but to say hey what what am
I interested in what do I want to invest
in I'm going to be a smart investor so
so the primary risk is is really
ignorance it's it's the biggest risk you
have you I can give you a list of
Burkshire hathways Investments give them
to someone who's ignorant say try to
copy this they can't do it because they
don't have the the investor education
very interesting so also you you you
used a phrase earlier that uh I think
it's worth understanding I think average
rate of return yeah cuz average rate of
return isn't the same thing as what rate
of return I might get you know over some
some period of time isn't there some
timing that has to do with that you know
it's a real big mistake if you read the
fine print one of the things you'll see
in every investor relationship any
document any uh interview for Discovery
or suitability interview is that prior
returns do not indicate future results
ever I think I've seen that once or
twice yeah and and so there if you look
and say well historically this has
happened to think that will happen in
the future look the world has changed
this is not your grandpa's thought
Market the volatility is greater the
amount of debt out there is greater the
amount of Leverage is greater and the
storm clouds I see from where I sit are
visible clearly visible um all you have
to do is look at the United States
government and say what does their
balance sheet look like yeah well they
certainly have a deficit that's sizable
we owe 20 trillion do on balance sheet
and then the promises to the Baby
Boomers in the hundreds of trillions W
um rough water if if you want to see
what's likely to happen look at
countries like Greece and Argentina and
uh and places like that where the fiscal
irresponsibility is spilled over in
their markets it's not a pretty picture
for the buy and holders of 401ks well
because I look and I say just using you
know very easy math if a stock market is
at five yeah and it goes to 10 it went
up by 100% it doubled doubled right then
if it pulls back down to five it reduced
by 50% now it has to double you got it
so so so now it's at the same level but
I could say there's an average of 50%
rate of return is that am I thinking
about it kind of right there well the
the the way to really think about it is
is this if I have
$100,000 and I have a big crash and
that's reduced to 50 I've had a 50% drop
right right but now I have to have a
100% gain to get it back to get it back
so the drop is always less but the
growth is always double and it's tough
to get 100% % so now I'm 100% convinced
education is a critical thing you ask
all the questions that I might not know
answers to and getting educated is
important and I think you made a good
point especially for professionals or
virtually anybody that it's it's not
like this is a rocket science type study
you know if you if you got some
especially higher education you know
this is not something that's going to
challenge you sure a decision to make is
this do you look at look at skills for
hiring your life you know a root canal
for me is a skill for hire delivering a
baby skill for hire right but they're
also life skills tying my shoes brushing
my teeth right unfortunately the
management of money has become a skill
for hire instead of being the life skill
that it really should be for every
person it's not taught in school most
people don't know the difference between
a deficit in a debt a balance sheet or
an income statement but I also say this
one of the blessings I have as a as a
person who was not a you know I didn't
go to the Wharton School of Business
okay I was a basketball player just
trying to stay eligible to play and so
for a guy like me of average
intelligence how do I do it I build a
team and most people are solos in their
life they go to work they have a boss
and they worry about themselves but when
you can surround yourself with great
people and great advisers and great
teachers that not just tell you what to
do but educate you on why you're doing
it uh having a great accountant having a
great bookkeeper even if you consider
yourself a low-income person having a
simple bookkeeper is not that expensive
to have on your team and to help you
with your discipline in investing and
saving having a great accountant having
great attorneys and great advisers
around you oh it can really pay
dividends in the future how do you vet
them I mean how do you know who's great
you know if you were an entrepreneur or
if you were a a person who wanted to be
an entrepreneur the first thing I would
say is what are you passionate about you
know because there's probably someone
making money in that passion yeah uh
there's a wonderful restaurant I love
locally and when he was a mortgage
broker and he loved to barbecue in the
backyard decided one day take the plunge
and start a barbecue and now you know he
sold that for millions of dollars and so
you find your passion and then you find
someone in there in that area and you
say who's your attorney who's your
accountant right who's on your team and
I found that's the best way to build a
team around you is to find people that
are doing what you want to do and say
hey who's on your team because likely
they'd be happy to be on your team as
well right that's and that's actually
really good advice referral word to M
that you kind of old fashioned if you
will y any other considerations so I've
got to get educated I got to build the
team any other considerations well I
will tell you this there are a lot of
storm clouds out there and there's a lot
of problems that that you can study but
there's silver linings on every one you
know as I look at at my own children I
get excited because there's never been a
better time to be an entrepreneur it's
never been easier to do the use of
technology and The Leverage we have with
communication and the web a person can
now start a business easier faster with
lower risk you can fail 10 times before
you get it right if you're willing to
miss the ball a few times it's easier to
do that now than ever before and the
other good news is is that for educated
investors crashes are actually
opportunities uh I get excited when
there's a pullback if you know how to
position yourself properly you might be
on the verge of some of the greatest
opportunities ever you know there's a a
book called The Big Short was put into a
movie not for the kides but put in for a
movie and people often walk out of there
say boy I wish I could see the
opportunity for a big short go look at
the United States balance sheet and your
opportunity is coming yeah so by getting
educated by building a team and
understanding that opportunity out there
to increase your wealth and prosper
individually is better than it's ever
been so and with that is that a reason
to maybe stay in cash rather than fund
uh you know a defined benefits of like a
401k so that when those opportunities
come you have some cash to be able to
take advantage of it I think you always
ought to have a little cash for rainy
day but I'll ask you this um do you
think the value of the dollar is going
to go up or down well it's going down
it's Noto if I told you gold was going
to go down would you hold it or get rid
of it get rid of it but you know what if
there was one asset I'd bet on losing
value it would be the US dollar right so
putting a lot of that in savings to me
doesn't really make a lot of sense uh if
I wouldn't hold gold if it was going
down if I wouldn't hold stock if it was
going down why would hold cash so I
think having some cash for an emergency
to to pay your bills is great but I
think it's one of the worst long-term
places uh you're just not going to
outpace inflation with the rate we're
printing money so I guess whever you did
put it if it's somewhat liquid because
like you say if there's a downturn in
the market um and saying now it's a
great time to buy uh you know you just
want to have the I guess the ability to
do that yeah you know one of the
important things that that I do
personally when I trade in stocks is I
always know an option is is people think
options are risky and options options
are insurance policies and the problem I
see with 40K is there's no insurance you
own a home if out a fire you'd have
insurance well which is more likely to
burn down the next 5 years your home or
your 401k right and so you can buy small
Investments this is what investors like
Mark cubin and Warren Buffett and George
Soros do is they buy small insurance
contracts uh to ensure their paper
assets just like they would a home or a
physical asset so with education there's
things you can do to protect yourself
there's things you can do to capitalize
on downturns and uh and and you know
diversification in stocks is not real
diversification the market goes down but
having real estate I love real estate I
love gold I love a lot of asset classes
but they all have their own risks right
and they all have their own set of
Education that helps a person understand
those risks and manage them properly
great well I really appreciate you
spending time a very illumin ating you
have to kind of get context for things
so thanks so much thank you so much for
having me and it's just been a
[Music]
pleasure you're in for a real treat this
interview is with Roger Hamilton and
here's what's interesting I had known
Roger casually meaning uh we had mutual
friends and I'd be in places with him
we'd have good conversation and I didn't
really get deep into his knowledge
understanding and wisdom I could tell
you one thing
he always had a light about him there's
just some energy that came off of him
that was very positive very engaging but
when I sat down to have an interview and
actually dig in to his view of things to
see his perspective then to understand
the wisdom that he's accumulated over
time I have to tell you I was so
thoroughly impressed and so excited and
took so many notes after the interview
that I had to write down saying gez I
need to remember this and I need to
remember that so many lines in there
that resonated with me that I can't wait
now to share this with you so enjoy my
interview here with Roger Hamilton Roger
really happy that you're here you're a
brilliant guy and I can't wait to hear
what you have to say about this topic of
money thank you and good to be here yeah
so you've got quite an entrepreneurial
background and you have certainly a lot
of perspectives around money and even
train entrepreneurs you know around
these concepts of understanding not just
you know how to make money but really
what money is and and you know how it
relates to human beings right um but
let's start kind of with your background
how how did you get into the stuff that
you're doing today totally by accident I
was actually studying architecture in
Cambridge uh my dad wanted to be an
architect I decided that's what I should
do as well and uh it was actually while
I was at uh college that I had my first
business experience and it really
started because I I was at the end of my
first year I was um uh rowing in the in
the in the um col College boat and I had
had my director of studies who said you
can't be rowing and you can't be doing
architecture at the same time cuz the
time commitment was so massive and he
actually warn me at the end of the first
year unless I could uh unless I could
actually spend the whole summer on my uh
portfolio uh then I was out so I was
like oh my gosh what am I'm going to do
CU I have to do that but I also know
that like my big dream is to be able to
get into the first boat which means I've
got to go on the training camp uh and in
addition to that all my friends who had
jobs down in London uh they were all
saving up to go to a trip in Greece and
I really wanted to do that but I had no
job uh because my parents were back in
Hong Kong they didn't know people in
London and so I was sitting down feeling
sorry for myself in the pub One Night in
pretty much the last week of uh school
before the break and and and I just got
a little uh pad and I wrote down uh what
if I was to add all three of my problems
together and turn it into a question and
so I said okay how would I uh make
enough money to go to Greece while being
on rowing cab and fill out my portfolio
and it was like Tada it's like from
there I was like okay I'm going to have
to do drawings in Cambridge for the
tourist uh so that I can actually uh do
that during the day make the money um
and then in the mornings I'll go rowing
and that's what I did from day one I
just went out there did this and I had
the most incredible experience making
more money by doing that than if I'd
gone and got a job in London and being
able to get into the RO camp and being
able to go uh and uh uh go to Greece and
all of this taught me that at any po
Point your problem is also your source
of your greatest profit uh and so from
there it really got me addicted to this
idea that I could always find a smarter
way to solve other people's problems and
that's really what entrepreneurs do and
one thing led to another um along with
uh pretty fateful uh uh like a view
Viewpoint I had from someone called Buck
Mr Fuller which switched the way that I
thought about my life and also got me on
this journey of being an entrepreneur so
what was it that you heard from Buck Mr
Fuller that uh that changed you well in
architecture we were learning about
different people that had all sorts of
inventions they had made for
architecture and he was the creator of
the getic Dome and uh one of the things
that I read up about him was he had this
concept which was called the final exam
and he said that all because he was a
futurist as well as an architect he said
that all of the world's challenges were
distribution challenges uh so for
example when you say there's poverty
it's not because there is enough money
it's just not distributed effectively or
if you say there's there's hunger right
it's not because there is enough food
it's just not distributed effectively
and he said that technology allows us to
distribute far more effectively and even
then in the 1970s there was already
enough technology to solve all the
world's problem so he said so why have
we not solved them and he said the
reason we haven't solved them is because
of our human consciousness and
Technology keeps accelerating
exponentially and so if we don't watch
out we have the possibility of actually
uh not passing this exam and if we don't
do that is the end of civilization he
says either Consciousness will
accelerate enough to harness that
technology and we will solve The World's
problems or it won't in which case
technology will eventually destroy us
and we have a window of time which you
didn't specify how how much that was but
I was guessing it's maybe 20 30 years
and I don't think we're too far out from
that in order for us to actually be able
to solve these challenges and for me
that was such a a massive shift in
thinking in terms of the fact that I'm
living at this time we're all living in
this point of time where it's a make or
break uh that I thought I shouldn't be
building buildings I should be building
businesses really designing the future
because you know as they say best way to
predict the future is to create it and
that's what entrepreneurs can do uh so
uh captivating you know that Vision that
he laid out out it's interesting that
many people uh they have that kind of uh
pivotal moment where you know from
something they heard something a mentor
said or whatever that like you know
light goes off and there they are but
I'm curious because you said you started
drawing you know in London you said that
was and and incidentally I don't want
this to go by too quick either you
solved your problems by what asking a
question yes so I want to learn more
about the details of how you solved it
but is it do you have a premise that uh
the quality of our outcomes is based
upon the quality of the questions we can
ask AB absolutely I I really believe
that we you know every day our life is
determined by the quality of our
questions and I mean the word quest in
questions is about that idea that
whatever Quest we're on today is the
size of the question I mean like if my
biggest question today is what I'm going
to have for lunch right that's as big as
today's going to get right but if I'm
thinking about what today I'm doing to
solve a much bigger problem uh whether
it's you know something that's going to
be an impact my family or something of
impact to a much wider Community well
then of course I'm going to be in a much
much bigger Quest so I think that's so
important I also think you know this
point about uh most people getting stuck
on problems as opposed to converting
those problems into questions and
realizing their source of their biggest
problem is also the source of the
biggest profit there's so many examples
of entrepreneurs that have said well
I've got this problem others probably
have this as well what's a way I can
figure out the solution to this and then
of course they're solving it not just
for themselves but for everyone else as
well well we definitely have to have
have a whole conversation around that
but I'm sorry that I'm so curious about
this but what what did you do to make
this money you said you're you're in
college you said I'm going to draw for
tourist so what'd you draw so yeah okay
so and by the way this idea of
Consciousness shifting which comes from
the quality of questions as well that
was my experience in my very first week
right so what what happened was I
thought oh gosh I've got to figure out a
way that I can get a drawing done every
day uh have people want to buy it as
well I I don't want to be able to just
you know draw and then just look for
someone to buy that drawing I want to
figure out a way to print it so I I
decided I was going to do them in black
and white of different like sites of
Cambridge I was going to basically sit
down on the spot be drawing during the
day so people could see me as they walk
by and freehand like an artist freehand
yeah so I did drawings of like you know
famous things like King's college chapel
and so on I do in black and white so I
could photocopy it I would make it the
right size so that I could actually get
freezer bags from Sainsbury's and make
it look really professional put it in
there I got a big sign up which
basically was a photocopy which cost 5 p
uh but it was a nice photocopy on nice
paper uh and where I said you know one
print for you know2 three prints for5
and and so I would have that like board
and then I'd start drawing and what
happened in the first day that I did
this was I made about 50s which is about
let's say1 at that time uh which was a
lot because most of my friends were
making maybe 200 a week in London and I
thought wow look I've just gone and made
100 and of course it's all cash so I'm
bringing this cash back and uh that
could have continued all week but what
was very interesting was because I had
already realized a PA of questions at
the end of the first day I asked myself
what would it take for me to make double
as much tomorrow uh and of course if
you're in a job you can't do that you
can't just determine your pay but but
for an entrepreneur you can do that so
so I said what would it take and what I
decided to do was because I didn't know
what the answer was was I start testing
things right so the next day I thought
well maybe it's about being in the right
place right time if I was in a busier
Place different time of day so I sat in
a different place and I started counting
every half hour how many people were
buying and how much they were buying and
I found that there was a pattern and the
pattern had nothing to do with the time
of day it had to do with how many people
were stopping if a lot of people stopped
then a lot of people born right and so I
started realizing that my real value
wasn't in just my drawing it was in my
ability to slow people down and so what
I started doing is realizing if I asked
people for the time they'd stop and then
others would stop I then soonly realized
that actually if I wasn't looking for a
person but a group like a family and
instead of asking for the time I'd ask
the child hey would you like to sit and
watch me draw and then of course they'd
say hey Mom Dad can I sit they'd sit
we'd have conversation everyone would
stop and then as a result I'd end up
making you know double triple as much
money during that time I ended the
second day and I'd actually made at that
point over 1001 so I doubled my money
and then I got to the end of the second
day and I said I'm going to ask the same
question again how would I double my
money the third day and the third day
started I went rowing in the morning it
was now about 10:00 which is normally
when I start the drawing I found another
spot most of the tourists don't show up
until lunchtime but as I was in this new
spot uh an American Tourist came along
and he was with his wife and he was just
walking along and he saw me starting to
draw dra this drawing and so he said to
me hey uh how much does it cost for that
drawing and I said oh what the one I'm
drawing now and he goes yeah and I said
no no no I'm not selling this this is my
original right and he goes oh no but
it's beautiful you've already started it
it looks fantastic I want to buy that
and I said I'm not selling this right
cuz you don't understand I actually
print this and then everyone you know
gets to actually have a piece of it and
and it's worth a lot more than if I just
sold it right now and he says oh come on
everything's got a price so that made me
think well maybe everything does have a
price and if it has a price what's the
price cuzz he's actually saying he wants
to buy it uh and this happens a lot I
realize people who want something from
someone and you're not willing to put a
price on it and then you're wondering
why you don't have the money so I
decided I decided to put a price on it I
said well I know that you know this
drawing today or this day itself will
will pay me100 cuz I knew that happened
yesterday so he actually pays me1 P now
I wouldn't have to do anything else for
the rest of the day so I
said1 and he said okay done but you want
to I want you sign you know Roger
Hamilton's unfinished original on it so
someone now has this picture somewhere
in the world actually he actually did
that I signed it he bought it for £100
and then I got the100 I was like wow
that was that was quick it's not even
like 11:00 I I made the money for the
day and then I stopped and then I
thought well what am I going to do today
because you know I've got the rest of
the day free and I don't actually feel
like I want to just go and just relax I
actually want to do this drawing and so
I just got another piece of paper out
and I started the same drawing again and
as it turned out that same drawing made
me another1 during the day and so I me
200 and it was that whole thought
process of realizing that the moment you
actually put out to the world the
question you don't even have to be the
one that comes off the answer you know
the moment you actually are out there
and we see this all the time today you
know you see Richard Branson saying
we're going to take people to space
right you got you know Elon Musk saying
you know we're going to figure out a way
to actually get off fosil fuels and and
they don't have the answer but just the
fact that they're sitting in the
question everything else shows up as
well so that idea of Consciousness
lifting through the quality of your
question you can double triple quadruple
your income and my whole life has been
about that ever since and helping other
people to do the same thing so it's
really fascinating that at this young
age that you're able to look at this
solve this problem you obviously were
geared to be an entrepreneur you know
you're unconventional in your in your
thinking thought experiment what if what
if say that first day it didn't go so
well or maybe the second day it didn't
go so well um what do you do you think
that would have changed things or do you
think you would have kept going and
figured it out I think uh that's a
really interesting question question
because I hadn't had enough of the
experience of the payoff of perseverance
at that point right so there's every
possibility I might have just quit and
said this is not the right thing to do I
think that I got to a point in the
number of times that I basically uh had
something that failed and then I saw the
result in a positive way after that that
today I would keep on persevering no
matter what having said that I think
that there were certain things I was
doing at the time which may actually
have made me also continue so for
example rowing is a really good example
like that's what I was doing and Rowing
is a crazy sport because you're looking
backwards the whole time you can't
actually make it work unless you're with
the team uh most of the time it's not
working uh and you have to persevere
persevere persevere right so I was
actually experiencing other parts of my
life where I was putting myself on the
line with others uh you know the power
of continuing even when things aren't
working right I think many people don't
have that experience and so because they
haven't had it it's really really easy
to just give up on things without
realizing that success is always just
that next step after you're actually
willing to sacrifice it all and I think
that's the big test most people don't go
with did you finish school I mean did
you get your degree in architecture or
what happened uh I got my first degree
which was for uh uh which was after
three years and then the RBA which is
the qualification to be a practiced
architect is a seven-year course I took
a year out and I realized in that year
out the actual decision- making on
design wasn't The Architects it was
actually the developers right and they
pay the Architects to do what they but
they could always veto the architect so
I remember saying to my Dad hey Dad I
really want to be a developer right and
he goes we didn't got the money to be a
developer be an architect first uh and
it was actually in my fifth year I
actually had the courage to say you know
what I'm I'm better off moving my
thinking especially with you know what
uh I said earlier around Buck Mr Fuller
and this idea that like time was so
short that it really was uh time to
shift from the idea of building
buildings luckily today I'm at I
actually called my dad and I said at the
time hey Dad I'm going to quit
architecture uh the reason is because I
really believe I could be a developer I
could be out there you know with
properties that I could then hire
Architects to do he says well good luck
with that uh and today that's what we're
doing with our Resorts around the world
and and so I'm I'm now designing more
than ever but I'm doing it with
Architects that are now working for me
so let's talk about your business
activities so there's there's Myriad
business activities for you uh you just
described one of them which is you have
Resorts around the world and I might say
uh I was looking at pictures of them
earlier beautiful Resorts around the
world the kinds of places I guess you
build the kind of places or buy the kind
of places you'd like to stay yet or
what's the theme in your Resorts uh
they're all they're all entrepreneur
Resorts actually so they're actually
designed for entrepreneurs to be able to
come on accelerated programs to be able
to come and take that time out and I'm a
great believer in the power of
environment so we have resorts in baliy
in South Africa on a safari in Thailand
these are Resorts that are giving you
the opportunity to get out of the city
environment uh and actually be able to
get a clear head to be thinking about
your future and where you want to go uh
and they there almost like a spiritual
experience when you're there you really
get this sense that there's something
bigger out there for you to actually
step into so the resorts are one one of
the businesses and entrepreneur resource
is a public listed company which is
growing at the moment with teams in
different countries uh then we have a
second company which is called geniusu
which is a te technology platform which
provides mentoring for uh you know any
entrepreneur around the world that wants
to get connected with other
entrepreneurs out there too uh and then
we have a third company which is
entrepreneurs Institute which is where I
do a lot of my training mentoring we
have events like the global entrepreneur
Summit that we run in different parts of
the world uh and what's really
incredible is that we have a front row
seat of the entire entrepreneur movement
you know this is something that's was
predicted some time back by the likes of
like Charles handy with the mty rain Cod
where he said we're all going to be
portfolio workers in the future and uh
you know the what interesting thing is
the global entrepreneur uh um monitor
which is like a a group around the world
that measures how many entrepreneurs
they are they predict there's going to
be a billion entrepreneurs by the year
2020 which is phenomenal because there
was only about 100 million in the year
2000 and
and like a billion people that's less
than the number of people that were on
the planet you know a century and a half
ago so this is like the biggest
vocational shift in the history of
mankind that we're actually living
through and we're getting to see that in
all these different countries in Asia in
Africa where we have all these people
who are deciding to be entrepreneurs
instead of employees uh as they're uh
you know even at teenage age is there
like a spirit being Unleashed you think
in the world you know that that's
causing you know this this big influx of
of entrepreneurs uh to enter the
marketplace yeah there's a word for it
which is entrepreneur Spirit right it's
like it's like there isn't a single
entrepreneur that doesn't get there
through entrepreneur Spirit uh what I
think is interesting is I think there
was a time when the idea of being an
entrepreneur was was like an opportunity
it was kind of like a well maybe I could
do it uh but the challenge with that is
you know when you go through school
school school is either training you to
be in a job or it's training you to go
to university right it's not training to
be an entrepreneur uh we're actually
getting to a time where being an
entrepreneur is no longer a maybe it's
actually a must uh is better job
security to be an entrepreneur which is
someone who knows how to create a job uh
than to be an employee which is someone
who has to wait and get a job because
there are so many there's so much risk
in terms of whether jobs will even exist
in the future uh in the way that they
are today so and that's I think I just
want to uh pause because you're you
you're you're saying so many things uh
and stringing them together that I think
are profound so in part your definition
of an entrepreneur is someone who says
I'm going to create a job as compared to
a non- entrepreneur would say I need to
go get a job absolutely yeah I mean like
if I have an employee mindset I say I
can't actually make money unless I can
go to the job ads or I can go to the job
boards and I can find someone who's
asking for a job and then I have to
compete with hundreds if not thousands
of other people for that same job right
right so that's that's what someone
who's got an employee mindset would do
and that's why there's such fear because
if someone doesn't give me that job I'm
not going to have money right whereas
someone who is an entrepreneur is
someone who doesn't start from there
they don't even look at the job board
they start by saying okay what what's
what's the person I really want to work
with right who would be my customer
who's person is going to give me money
and how can I make sure I can do
something of real value to solve their
problem which means going to whoever it
is you want to work with and finding out
what the biggest problem is and then
helping them to solve that and even
being willing to say look I'll give you
some of my time for free to show you
that that I can be trusted to help you
solve your problem you help someone
solve a problem that puts money in their
pocket they're always going to be paying
you for it yes uh and so if you have
that thought process it doesn't just
give you job security for life because
you can always create a new job like all
the entrepreneur friends I have none of
them are worried about uh not having a
job or not having a business cuz they
can always start a new one they know how
to do that but of course the power of
that is you're not just creating a job
for yourself if you know how to create a
job you can create it for everyone else
around you which means you can create it
for your children right you can CH
create it for the people you love uh you
don't ever have to be in a situation
where you feel the pain of someone that
you really care for having to basically
suffer because they didn't understand
that it was all there in front of them
and all they had to do was create that
value instead of waiting for someone
else to come and see the value in them
so also I think uh maybe furthering that
with your college experience in that
case you're taking something that you
had a skill uh about you know because
you were going to be an architect so
obviously you can draw and uh yeah you
had to have some kind of a passion for
it and he said maybe there's a you know
some demand for this out there and you
went and tested it and cost you almost
nothing to go test it that's right right
and and you saw results right away and
you kept asking questions you know that
kept you know leading you to Higher and
Higher Ground so uh I think what happens
a lot times is that maybe people or tell
me if this is your experience but maybe
people say Hey you know I do have a
talent and something I'd love to do but
I just don't believe that I can make
money doing this or maybe it's something
from their mothers fathers teachers
preachers you know told them that you
know no you have to go get a job working
a company you'll climb a ladder get
benefits oh my God if you if you're an
entrepreneur if you go to do something
on your own you're not going to have
benefits how are you going to live
without benefits right right so so what
what is the the barrier do you think is
the biggest barrier that Entre that
potential entrepreneurs face trying to
get into a you know get into making a
job for themselves uh our biggest
barrier by far is our own mindset I mean
first of all by far and I'll give you an
example of Shifting mindset so uh my son
when he was 16 years old he had to do a
class project as it was everyone else in
the class and you had to present the
project at the end of the year and he
decided that because he had a very
mathematical mind and we had gone on
trips to Italy where he had learned all
about the golden ratio and the beauty
and all of that and he told you know
math has got a basis in Beauty so he
decided that what he was going to do was
he was going to create a series of
building blocks called the Fibonacci
blocks and the whole concept of the
Fibonacci blocks was it was taking it
off someone called Frederick fubo who
was like the founder of the kindergarten
who said like kids think spatially and
he had this like wooden block set that
he created so he took that same concept
of wooden block set but he designed them
all in the dimensions of the Fibonacci
series and he went out looking for how
he could get this done in barley cuz
that's where we're living and he came to
me and he said how do I know if this is
even worthwhile and I said the way you
know if something's worthwhile is people
are willing to buy it right if
something's actually got something that
people say that's of enough value to me
that I'm willing to actually pass you
money for that thing you're on the right
track so why don't you turn this into a
crowdfunding project uh and he thought
well that's interesting he actually set
up an Indiegogo campaign where he
actually put on there his Fibonacci
blocks this was before he had even had
them produced yet and that was the the
barriers like well how do I actually get
the resources to be able to make these
blocks but by putting it on there he
started seeing all these people getting
really excited about the idea of having
their blocks they started actually
paying money into to this bank account
that he saw go to $1,000 then 5,000 then
10,000 then $20,000 and this was all
within a matter of weeks and as he saw
this growing he was like wow I'm going
to have to scale up my production here
and but it allowed him to now have the
resources that before he didn't have as
a result of showing the value first um
it actually got to a point where he came
back one day and he says hey I've been
updating my teacher on what's been
happening with this project but my
teacher was really enthusiastic to begin
with and now like the last thing she
said was you know stop showing off she
and and I don't know why she's saying
that and so I sat him down and I said
well well you've seen where your numbers
have just gone to you just gone over
$20,000 within like a matter of like 10
days do you know how much the average
teacher makes in a year and he's like
$20,000 and I go pretty much right here
in Bary that's what they're getting and
and that teacher isn't going to
understand how you just made as much
money in a classroom project within a
week week and a half that she makes an
entire year uh and once he got that and
he realized that it wasn't his problem
that she was feeling that way or others
were feeling that way he continued on
and that project went over $40,000
before it was done and he turned that
into his own little business off the
back of it uh but that mindset shift was
just that idea of saying well what if
instead of me waiting for the resources
before I go forward or instead of
complaining about the fact I don't have
things what if I turned it all around
and said whatever value I have I want to
share that with people to see if they
see value in it as well and if they do
and they're paying for it I I really
believe that every kid should have a
crowdfunding campaign just to test this
concept before they leave school because
it is about that shift and mindset once
you've had that one thought you're
always going to be able to actually go
and repeat it again at larger and largic
scale and that is the free market right
I mean that's what capitalism is all
about saying you know somebody produces
something and the market decides if it
has value or not and nobody can force
anything upon anybody else it's free
exchange I really believe that
entrepreneurship is one of the very very
best ways to get to self-awareness I
think it's really easy to be in a job or
to be in a situation where you're not
actually getting the the mirror
reflection of yourself uh in the same
way you do as an entrepreneur where
where if you don't have something of
value it becomes really clear really
quick because no one's paying you money
for it right but the moment you do have
something of value you know it and and
the market gives you direct feedback
especially today where everything's
online where everyone can find the
things they like very quickly and move
away from things they don't like uh so
your ability to every day get another
lesson in self awareness
whether it's a hard lesson or whether
it's one that puts money in your pocket
right which is why I say as an
entrepreneur you're always either
earning or learning that's a brilliant
Insight uh to say that being an
entrepreneur is a path to self-awareness
right so that's sort of this more
spiritual side saying you know how am I
going to get to know myself understand
who I really am what what really matters
to me and when you're working 9 to5 you
know in a the confines of a of a job
that you have maybe just because you
need to survive compared to say h how
would IPR myself and what would people p
me for that you know it's really two
different things and and it goes very
deep because like we have so many
Frameworks within the things that I
teach which are based on self-awareness
and self-mastery I I believe
entrepreneurship and this whole idea of
raising Consciousness comes from three
three things selfawareness then
self-mastery then self- expression right
and you can only get to self- expression
which is where all the money gets made
if you've actually got clear and self-
awareness first so as an example the
Japanese have this concept which is
called IAI uh which is your reason for
being and it's not it's more than just
purpose on its own it's the combination
of what you love which is your passions
what the world needs which is your
purpose what you're good at which is
your talents and then what you get paid
for which is your business model and
it's the intersection of all four
because you can do something that can
pay you really I mean there people have
a job or their life and they go well I'm
getting paid well so I got to stay in
this job but it's it's not their passion
uh which means that they're actually
getting into poor health because of it
they're losing energy because of it uh
is not their purpose which means it's
meaningless it's not something which
actually drives them so it's about how
do you really every day with the
business that you start make sure that
to begin with you've got a way to ensure
you really are passionate about it so
you're energized every day that you've
got something that's purposeful which
means that you're going to be doing it
even in the tough times that is
something that's following your talents
which allows you to build a team of
other people who've got different
talents then the business model will
always be there for you because there's
always whatever you're going to do
someone else in the world who has got
very much the same purpose talents and
passions but has figured out a way to
already be making 10 times what you're
making right and so by just
understanding and learning from them
there's always a way to be able to make
the money uh most people just aren't
thinking that way which is why they're
then trapped in their own mindset
there's a significant wealth Gap that's
emerging and I think growing greater
every single day um and uh it's a
disturbing Trend to many people other
people say it's just a natural way of
things how are you seeing this I think
there's a big misunderstanding of what
the Gap actually is you know there's all
these reports that constantly come out
about how the top 1% earns so much of
the world's wealth without realizing
that this Gap isn't about a pie where
because someone's got the pie you don't
have the pie right the wealth in the
world is always growing right like like
my son with his Fibonacci blocks you
know Luke didn't Luke didn't take money
from anybody right it's like he was
creating new value that wasn't there
before right so the way I see the Gap is
it's a little bit more like you know if
you and I went for a run and there was a
race going on one of us would beat the
other one and that Gap would be the just
the difference between what you have and
what I have right um if you happened to
get on a bicycle because you figured out
there was a way to get there faster and
I wasn't even thinking of a better way I
wouldn't go any faster and the Gap
suddenly gets bigger right and if that
bicycle becomes a car and then you then
upgrade to a rocket ship and you get
look if I have a better vehicle right
I'm going to be able to get much further
than I could before and you're you're
not even trying to beat me you're just
beating yourself right right I mean
that's what Mark Zuckerberg did that's
what Jeff bezos's done it's what Elon
Musk is doing they're they're just
finding smarter and smarter business
models that allows them to go faster and
further than they did before uh someone
who's in a job or someone who isn't
thinking in that way they're just
running right they're just using their
own energy their own time and of course
that means the Gap gets bigger because
what they then can earn in the day is
totally different from someone who's
actually got vehicles and mechanisms to
add a lot more value with a lot more
people to be able to get there a lot
faster and so like if you I shouldn't
complain and try try and knock you off
your car motorbike in order for me to
feel better about you going slower I
should just say well I can learn how to
also get the motorbike or you know and
there's plent like every there's enough
motorbikes for everybody right there's
enough complaints for everybody uh and I
really believe that today there's enough
even education available for people to
understand how to fly right uh it's just
that most people aren't aware of it um
or they're too busy kind of running to
even stop and actually say wait let me
just take the time to fly and start that
business or that investment vehicle uh
because everyone who's actually most
successful the the BR richer brand of
the world they write it down that
they're telling us how to do it right
and so that's where we're living in in a
world today which we weren't living in
quite the same way 50 years ago so
there's a real advantage today but you
have to take it well it's interesting
your your analogies are really good
because um what what's encouraged in a
free market is for people to figure out
a bicycle than a car than a rocket ship
what have you uh in oppressive type uh
economic environments or or political
environments um pretty much uh like it's
like hey get off your bike and start
walking again you know you're you can't
go that far out ahead it's not permitted
it's not allowed it's shared misery in a
sense so you you got to move as slow as
everybody else maybe a little bit faster
is okay but you can't like just get on a
bike or get in a car and that basically
forces everybody down right doesn't
allow emergence of of better quality of
life well in the case of
Entrepreneurship it's actually almost
the opposite I mean if you go to Africa
uh if you go to China
uh India you're seeing a much much
faster rate of growth in
entrepreneurship than you see in America
only because the environment arounds
allowing it now whereas maybe some years
ago it didn't right uh yes and no
because I think there's always an
alignment between value creation which
is where entrepreneurs start showing up
and even in dictatorships even in
oppressive societies they still are
looking for everyone to be as productive
as possible right and so if someone
actually is able to start a business in
some way and that then actually helps
the government right it takes people
into jobs and so on then then they're
not going to be against it necessarily
so I think there are a lot of things
that uh such as free speech and so on
which which which are the kind of things
that government's going to be more
focused at uh but from and as long as
the government's getting paid and
they're getting their taxes right
they're going to be continuing to move
on but I think that today there is less
of an excuse than ever really in any
country uh for someone to say the reason
I can't be successful is because of the
government or because of large
corporations or because of the weather
right like there is less excuse excuses
available today than ever uh and I think
that's a really really important thing
because it's the the easiest thing if
you have the wrong mindset to put in the
way of success yeah I agree I think you
know probably ever since the end of the
Cold War you know uh that's where we
started to see that things started
emerging me you the fact when China
started becoming more and more more
productive you know you know what they
become as an economic superpower now uh
but because people individually can
benefit from their success as compared
to saying we're going to take it all
from you and you know gets recirculated
and everybody has to have the same
income so it's so now I guess is a great
time to be an entrepreneur right uh I
think it's an amazing time and I'd say
that the the the bigger thing that I
think generally stops people from from
the idea of going out and being
financially successful even more so than
the government or anything external
there is their own belief uh that making
money in some way is evil or in some way
is the opposite of making a difference
uh you know it's like profit and purpose
Pur don't go hand in hand uh and there's
a lot of reason for people to think that
20 years ago right because the whole
basis of running a business was it was
there for the shareholders for the for
the people that wanted you to make
profit so how could you go and make a
difference um if you had to go and make
all the shareholders happy now all
around the world we've seen this massive
Trend towards social entrepreneurship
towards you know like social corporate
responsibility where even the biggest
companies in the world now are saying
actually we we can link purpose and
profit together right we can make income
we can make impact and in fact because
we have so so many conscious uh uh
people who are consumers now who would
much rather eat healthy food or you know
have more responsible healthare or uh
are going to make sure that um they're
only going to be working with companies
that are making a difference with the
environment right that that because
there are so many people now saying
that's the company we want to actually
be going for uh then we'd much rather
work with them you know Jeff bezo says
you know there's only two kinds of
entrepreneurs in the world as
missionaries and mercenaries uh and the
irony like missionaries are the ones who
do it for the mission mercenaries do it
for the money and and the irony today is
that it's actually the missionaries that
make the most money right it's possible
to do both at the same time so anyone
who's still got that excuse which is
like no like making money and means that
I'm not being meaningful or it means
that I'm not making a difference uh they
can't have that excuse anymore because
the reality is the best way to make a
difference is to be doing it in a way
where you're truly delivering value to
as many people as possible yeah and that
really is in a true free market you know
where where there's not um you know uh
any type of manipulation of that
Marketplace then in the end that's what
it is you basically uh the more people
you bring value to the more money you
make and it's kind of a simple uh
justice isn't it the people do the most
good should get the most reward it's
kind of like that simple yeah absolutely
I think that there is a fear that many
people have which is that either they're
not good enough right or that someone
else is already doing it so why even
bother without realizing There's 7
billion people on the planet today right
and there's always someone somewhere who
has a problem they want solved and if
you can show yourself to care enough
about them to want to to solve their
problem for them there's always money
there for you uh there's always a job to
be created and when once you understand
that and get that the concept of the
lack feeling that you have which is like
oh my gosh there's not enough really
goes away and it's easier said than done
but if you surround yourself with other
entrepreneurs if you go into
entrepreneur environments and we have
them all over the world right and when
people show up there they're like like
finally I don't have to be spending all
my time in fear or worry because there's
an actual way here that I can always
make sure that I've always got enough
right uh we had uh within our uh Resort
and barley we had someone who came out
from um from Europe here from the
Netherlands and he was a top trainer in
the Netherlands and and he said I've got
an issue with my mindset I've got to
change the way I'm thinking and I said
well you'll change it here right because
when you get here you have a whole
different relationship money he says I
don't understand what you mean by that
and I said well just just spend a few
days here you see what I mean next day
morning time comes he comes in and he
he's so excited and he says to everyone
there in the accelerator program he says
what Roger said yesterday I so get it
already and everyone's like well what
happened and he goes ah well I was like
you know just going for a walk this
morning and I go into the village uh and
um there's a market there right and
they're selling bananas and you would
not believe it but like you know where
I'm at in Netherlands you know it's like
what is it like 51 EUR to buy my bananas
and here I am and and he's telling me
the price of the bananas and it's like
less than a Euro and I go my gosh I'm
spending all my time like working for
what like for for expensive bananas
right and I can get them so cheap here
in Bali I mean I could already be
financially free just living here right
and and then he brings this I bought the
bananas right and I look at him and I'm
like why would you buy the bananas when
there's a banana tree
outside boy you just po that balloon but
that's but but everything's already out
there you know one of the uh one of the
schools that I am a big fan of and I and
I my my kids went there it's a green
School in barley and uh and I set up it
was John John and Cynthia Hardy who set
up the green school I I set up the board
there when I when I joined and and the
green school is really grown and and
it's got a big name all around the world
even though it's in a small small island
like barley and as an example uh when
when the kids go to Art you know we
don't think about the fact when kids go
to Art in the Western World we're
teaching them dependency like we're
saying hey here's the paints here's the
paper and so then you know you're
teaching them you can't actually paint
unless you have the paints in the paper
it's like you can't make money unless
you have a job uh in the green school
they start by saying okay let's talk
about paint where does paint come from
right it's like paint comes from nature
right and how would we make purple paint
right like let's start with let's start
with beetroot or let's the difference of
when we start like with a with an
eggplant and how do we turn that into
paint and so the kids make their own
paint in the in the class how do you
make paper right well you can take cow
dong and you can turn into paper the
kids are making paper and so what the
kids learn is not is not dependency
they're learning sufficiency right
self-sufficiency that no matter what I
can create something from nothing
because nature already provides
everything and the moment we get that
then we never have any fear whatsoever
about wealth you know I say true wealth
is not how much money you have it's what
you're left with if you lose your money
if you can lose all your money and still
be absolutely okay because you have the
ability to make it at any point right
that's true Freedom uh and everyone can
get there much faster than they think
and that is really a um I think a
profound um
observation is that you know if you if
you have money wealth can always be at
risk one way or the other there could
always be at risk but so you never feel
free if you have that fear attachment
but if you're saying I'm self-sufficient
not because I have all this money in the
bank because I am who I am and I can
recreate it which means that now I don't
have to worry and maybe I can go cut
some bananas down in B and I'll be just
fine a mentor of mine way back in my
early 20s said to me uh the true key to
success is gratitude and the best way to
exercise gratitude from a financial
point of view is to give yourself a
thought experiment every day which is to
ask yourself what would I been doing
today if I knew knew that tomorrow
morning I'd lose everything right like
what would I do today and of course if
you think about what you would do if
You' lose every I mean even if you're
very successful right um what you'd be
doing is you'd be investing time in your
relationships you'd be investing time in
adding value to people you'd be
investing time in seeing where
opportunities are today you'd definitely
make sure you're up to date with the
latest things that are going on and as a
result of all those things you'd be very
comfortable that you could Le leave
tomorrow and then you be able to start
all over again I still do that today
because the other thing it does is as
you start building assets in Building
Wealth it's too easy to take all of
those things as you right the biggest
thing that stops people from moving
forward is the Comfort level they have
with where they're at to say I don't
want to risk what I've got without
realizing that because of that they're
not doing the things that they'd
otherwise be doing investing in the
relationships investing in the knowledge
uh so most people think well I'm just
going to spend my time trying to hold on
to what I've got instead of actually
realizing you know what I could actually
be growing these other areas of my life
already you know there's three different
types of capital that make up all
selfworth m and wealth and if you think
about it like an iceberg where the top
of it is financial Capital uh most of
the world just sees people with
financial capital and they think well
they're the wealthy people but the only
way they got to that Financial capital
is having invested their time in Social
Capital which are the people they know
and in intellectual Capital which are
the this knowledge they've built and the
and the products they've made and if you
focus at just those two Social Capital
every day like what who am I meeting new
that are the right people I should meet
with who what are the things I'm
learning U it's just inevitable that if
you follow the right pathway your
financial Capital will result from these
two and when if your financial Capital
gets taken away these two don't go away
you still got them you know when Elon
mus 10 years ago was broke because he
had invested all his money in Tesla in
SpaceX you know he was sleeping on Peter
Teal's floor but Peter till himself was
like very wealthy and he had the right
contacts in the right way that he
invested which allowed him to actually
get out of that situation in a way that
if he wasn't thinking about that and he
was just thinking about trying to do it
himself he would be broke today and I
think that's one of the most important
things for most people is that you still
got the time outside of a job or still
got the time outside of whatever you're
doing right now to be building those two
uh and doing it every day so then it
gives Credence to the concept of you got
to be really careful about who you're
hanging out with absolutely right
because a lot of people are hanging out
with commiserators that talk about you
know how the rich have all the advantage
and poor us and you know we're
downtrodden and if that's your mindset
then you're not building relationship or
or Social Capital yes it's better to try
to find the people that uh that are what
you aspire to be and around them
absolutely and one of the things that I
find really interesting is that that
that thought process which is hang
around with people who are at a high
level is something that people hear but
then the question is well how do I do
that right how do and one of the most
important things is to know there are
Frameworks that now exist in the same
way that you know if you think about
flying a plane if anyone says could I
really fly a plane the answer is 100%
you can but you got to go and make sure
you've gone to flight school and you've
learned how a plane flies and you've
flown enough hours with someone who
flies as well so with entrepreneurship
is exactly the same thing and just
without going into detail of it a number
of the Frameworks that we've created
that now we've had what close on a
million entrepreneurs around the world
that have taken are things like our weal
Dynamics test which shows you that
you've got a natural path out of eight
to create your true self in your natural
flow your true wealth so Richard Branson
as a Creator is going to make his money
by being really good at creating new
ideas and then from there he's going to
have a team that can actually execute
right or Warren Buffett isn't interested
in new ideas he's going to be investing
in the things that are actually proven
ideas already and he's called
accumulated has got a very very
different uh set of um talents that he
uses and understanding when you know the
framework that the way to really build
your success is by getting the right
team in place of different uh talents uh
that's one really critical thing and
then we have something called the world
Spectrum which actually is that there's
nine levels of consciousness and if you
really want to lift your Consciousness
Next Level don't try and just spend all
your time with a millionaire who doesn't
actually see how you're going to deliver
value to them spend your time with
someone who's at one level up who
already is needing you to help them in
their business and then from there you
become their level then you go another
level up where now you've got a high
performing team then another level up
where you're able to be an investor and
each one of these doesn't take that long
to get through but most of us are trying
to trampoline our way to success and
they're wondering why we keep falling
back to where we started as opposed to
taking the ladder where there's one
specific step at a time so this is a
really good segue into an area I want to
explore so now you're very compelling
everything you're saying you know people
out there like okay I'm waking up uh I
think I want to be an entrepreneur I
shouldn't be doing what I'm doing going
to this job every day there's no future
in it for me and I'm not fulfilled by it
um so do they just jump right in or is
there a preparatory part of this how
does this all work the most important
thing is to know where you're at and
then where you're going like to get a
really clear idea of your vision of
where you're going and then to realize
that wherever you are right now there's
always going to be a first step and so
I'll just give you an example of that
like if we look at uh these nine levels
I mentioned you know the the bottom
level and and we actually put it into
something called a lighthouse because it
is about you setting turning on your
light and and the bottom level level
which is the infrared level which is the
victim is someone who's in debt and
going in more and more debt every single
month now this is not good debt that's
making you money and making you cash
flow positive this is debt that's making
you cash flow negative right and if
someone's at that level I've seen way
too many people you know quit their job
jump into infrared level where they're
just emitting heat waves now where
they're in a panic cuz they actually are
running out of time I mean really like
like they're running out of money and if
you're at that point where you need it
more than people need you you're never
going to win right especially if you're
trying to do it on your own so at that
point a lot of people say yeah but Roger
you said I should follow my passions
right and I'm like not at infrared level
right at that level like if you're overc
consuming right if you're overc
consuming and you are wanting to go on a
diet right uh imagine having a dietitian
who comes up and says oh the diet you
need to go on given that you've eaten
too much is um Follow Your Passion so
what are you passionate about chocolate
cake that's what got you in trouble
right so so you can't start by just
doing whatever you're passionate about
you have to start by earning the right
to even be playing the game okay right
which means that you've got to be at
that point saying am I willing to put
aside whatever I want people to come uh
and and get from me because I'm trying
to get from them and instead of that
focus at how can I actually serve others
like how can I connect with who actually
has a problem that I can serve in such a
way I can be making money by helping
them to be able to make more money and
that's something which for someone who
starts off is so foreign because so
often they think I've just got to go and
figure it out for myself but the moment
you think in that way you get connected
to the flow then instead of instead of
you know being in a desert where you're
digging a hole you're now in a river
where you're digging a tributary you're
actually digging a flow off that and
that gets you the positive cash flow
which then allows you to go up to Red
level which is survivor mode that's when
you're making just enough money to have
nothing which probably I would say 70%
of all Americans and uh all around the
world uh the middle class are people who
may have a little bit of money but most
of the time they end up spending what
they have uh and the challenge with that
is your business will always be a mirror
of yourself so this was a hard lesson
for me in my 20s I was trying to make
businesses make money but I wasn't
myself being cash flow positive I wasn't
reinvesting the money buying properties
buying assets making sure they were
making money for me and so why would the
money come my way money is always trying
to find the best home and if I'm not
able to appreciate the money the money
won't appreciate so as a result of that
I never could get those businesses to
work and it was only when I started
actually focusing on my own wealth and
actually being a asset to my business
instead of a liability the business then
started working as well and then from
that you got a number of different
levels right you've got orange level
which is a worker who knows it's all
about work ethic now the yellow level is
the person who says I can now make the
music the player um but like a guitar
player if you stop playing the music
then the music stops so lots of
solopreneurs who can't get away from
their business because they've got to be
there to make the money so solopreneurs
got a job maybe they created the job but
it's still a job it can actually wor in
some way right because they think at
least I could quit the job but with this
I got to keep on doing it and I got work
nights and weekends and I don't get
overtime that's right that's right
there's lots of professionals there's
doctors there's there's dentist uh
lawyers and and they're thinking I'm
trapped in this because I'm selling my
time without realizing you have to raise
your Consciousness to get from yellow to
Green which is from a player to
performer and realize if I'm a performer
in a band I can even leave the stage and
the music's still playing right so so
how do I do that and the answer is by
understanding that someone at that level
is no longer asking the question how do
I make money they're actually at the
next level up asking question how can I
help other people make money these are
all linked by the way to the Shakra
systems right so I know it's red orange
yellow oh yeah and yellow is very much
about willpower so if you're at that
level where you're going I'm making
money but I'm trapped in my job it's
because you're coming from a place of
will you probably got a long to-do list
you're probably all the time saying what
I will do is this I will do this um and
you're asking questions all about
yourself uh by Green level which is
heart chakra you're no longer saying I
will make money you're saying I will
help other people make money you know
and that means you're going to have
Partners you're going to have team
members and you're thinking if I hire
that person how much money can I make
for them and then of course you're going
to attract the right people in and
instead of instead of there being you
know saying I'm going to be one person
doing all things it's like no I'm going
to be I'm going to having all people
doing one thing right and I I means I
going to choose one thing that I'm going
to do well and then others can do the
other and so opposite thinking yes which
is I think one of the biggest challenges
with Consciousness in general and
Entrepreneurship in particular they have
glass ceilings where just like gears in
a car you're going to end up burning
yourself out by just trying to keep
accelerating when in fact what you
should be doing is taking your foot off
the accelerator and then up up gearing
upshifting to another gear right which
if you get that then it's like ah okay
I'm at that point where just working
harder is not the answer anymore um I
say one thing which as a thought
experiment which gets quite a number of
people I speak to to wake up which is
just asking them to imagine if they
think it's possible that there is
someone else in in the world right now
today there's someone else out there who
is not as smart as them who is not as
hardworking as them uh who is not as
talented as them uh who may not even be
as old as them they might be a lot
younger and they're already having 10
times the Inc income 10 times the impact
right the vast majority of people in the
world can imagine it in fact they know
it's true and so the question is well
what is that person doing different if
it's none of this stuff it's not about
hard work it's not about any of those
things and almost always it's about the
fact that they just took a pause and
came up with a business model which is
appropriate for their Market in today's
market uh and if everyone does that then
they suddenly realize even a successful
entrepreneurs realize holy cow there's
another level I could be going to right
now which would make all the difference
um and one example just uh just to
finish off on these lines if you go
above the green level performer the the
blue level conductor that's the person
making all the music without touching
any of instruments right you know so
this is the person that people think of
as the investor the the person that owns
all the properties has all the assets um
they talk about multiple streams of
income but you can't just Leap Frog up
to that because the only reason they've
got multiple streams is because they got
multiple teams conductor can only
conduct if they've attracted performers
right and you can't just expect that you
can earn the right to attract performers
right now cuz they're already going to
the best conductors so you have to take
one step at a time and say how do I
really make sure that I'm building the
three levels of trust the three levels
of trust are internal trust which is
your confidence so when you start off
your confidence can be very low and
that's okay you just got to build it
step by step external trust which is
even more important as credibility which
is how much do people actually believe
in you and your ability to deliver and
you don't have to start by trying to
create the credibility from scratch you
can partner with someone who's already
got that credibility even the Amazon and
the Facebooks of the world are
partnering with anyone who wants to
partner with them and you've already got
the credibility of the best in the world
right and then the most important of all
of the uh elements of trust is
predictability which is your ability to
trust someone that what they say is
going to happen in the future actually
happens all the billionaires on the
planet the only reason they're
billionaires is because they've told
people what they're going to do with
Amazon or you know with uh Microsoft and
so as a result of saying what's going to
happen with the company and people
believing in their predictability those
companies become worth billions if not
trillions of dollars right okay so now
you're that's the conductor level and
what's interesting I think you pointed
this out but I'm going to you know maybe
underscore it a bit is that a lot of
times people are saying oh look at this
success story do you see how they don't
do the work and you know they have other
people and they're like okay well I
start there and they don't realize
there's a process to get there and uh
and I think from the color spectrum
standpoint too you're looking at higher
and higher frequencies on the W you know
so so the wavelengths become higher
frequency as you're moving up so that's
another part I think of the the they're
moving up but they're still built on the
ones below right so some like a
conductor has people who are performers
that are high performing that are their
CEOs they have high level yellow people
who are are the guys that actually can
deliver profit and loss and build it
right but but you have to earn your way
to this level uh and it's amazing how
many people want to be the captain of
the football team and they haven't even
played the game yet right yeah yeah
that's great well stated so now you go
to Indigo yeah so the last three are
where I guess really exciting right
because like the first are I call a
foundation prism because it's about your
own personal flow so the idea of like
everything from infrared victim up to
the worker and by the way going to the
education system gets you to worker
right it's like okay now you have enough
money provided there's a job there for
you whereas the next three create their
own job right yellow green and blue is
the is the Enterprise prism which is
where all the flow of the market happens
and it's pretty incredible if you think
that every single day there's some 9
trillion doar a day of money that's
changing hands and you're going to be as
one of the people that the money's
actually changed hands with because
you're adding something of value and you
can turn it on you know like tomorrow um
but outside of the Enterprise when
you've earned the right and the trust of
the market you've then got the Alchemy
prism which is when you can change the
world right and those last three the
Alchemy prism Alchemy prism those are
the top three they're the top three yeah
love they're the ones who get to the
light and and the and the the here's a
really powerful thing the people in the
alching prism who think of this like a
theater where the where the first three
are the ones in the audience right
there're still there but they're not or
even a sports theater like a stadium
right they're the ones watching the game
lots more of those people than the
people on the pitch the next three are
the ones on the pitch or the ones on the
stage the final three you may not even
see them but they're the ones that
created the entire theater right so the
one up at Indigo level is a trustee so
trustee has got such trust now they can
make millions and minutes out of their
trust you know Richard Branson is at
trustee level right which means that you
know because he is trusted for being uh
like a Maverick entrepreneur people want
to use a virgin brand they'll pay him
Millions just to use the version brand
uh one level up from the trustee is
where the action starts happening which
is the composer right the composer which
is the Violet level is where you're now
making the music MH the taxes we pay
today the um laws that we follow today
uh these are all as a basis of a
composition that someone created today
we're entrusting politicians who have
never proven themselves to be good
composers right I mean they Prov
themselves to be very strong yellow
level politicians right to get into
office but but they're not necessarily
the ones who know how to actually be a
to shape an entire Society uh there's
entrepreneurs today like like Elon Musk
or Bill Gates who actually have put
themselves at composer level when
they've got such trust they're saying if
I was to set up a society in Mars here's
how I would do it right or if I was to
rethink how we actually look after
Healthcare in the third world here's how
we would do it and people are listening
to that because they're already have
proven themselves in the trust they can
have and then the final level is Legend
which is ultraviolet so Legend is the
likes of the Steve Jobs and Elson
mandelas of the world where just like on
a map the Legends don't even have to
have a have any writing right they're
the symbol of their time and uh everyone
on this planet has the ability to be
leaving here as a legend but you have to
earn your way there and too many people
want to go out there and change the
world but they're not willing to change
themselves right so it really starts by
saying what Journey do I need to go on
to get to that point where the real
things I want to have happen in this
world are happening because I've earned
my way up to that level and I'm working
with others that are working up that
level as well a final thing I'll say on
that is I think what inspires me so much
about the entrepreneur movement mement
is if you look at the people in the
world who are the ones talking the most
about making a difference in the
environment or in equality or in you
know an end to Poverty uh it isn't
really the governments and it's not even
the large corporations it is the
entrepreneurs that are knowing that the
best way to you know get to the Future
you want best way is to be able to
create the future right and so that
predictability comes from that ability
to say if I can have enough other people
that are on this journey with me then I
have the ability to like be a symbol on
the map right and leave a real Legacy
what are some practical things somebody
can do to uh to enter this Arena to get
started here uh okay I give you really
really simple one which is just
relationship with money itself it's
amazing to me just how much because of
the way the banking system works that
you're kind of encouraged that you just
basically set up One bank account where
you kind of throw everything into it
right which is a little bit like if you
were basically a chef and you were to go
out and get a lot of really great food
to actually use in your recipe and then
you just bu put it all into one big
bucket right and so so many people are
like I can't manage my money but it's
because they didn't they never set up a
pathway that respects the flow of money
in the first place and so the way we
always work with people within our
community is we start by saying just
organize the money in a simple easy way
which allows you to understand how money
itself changes its nature as it goes
from cash flow to profit to Capital and
the way we do it is we say go back down
to your bank manager tell your bank
manager that you want to reorganize your
bank accounts because you actually are
expecting a lot of money coming your way
which is the truth cuz a lot of money is
going to come your way and then you
think about it from the point of view of
first of all setting up one account
which is your clearing account the
clearing account most people don't have
it's an account where every single month
without fail is going to go down to zero
right if you got a clearing account
that's going to go down to zero then it
means that you know whatever is going to
go in is all going to go out and then
from there you then have a number of
very important accounts think of this
clearing account being like in the first
Lane of the highway and then it's going
into two other things that are going to
pay for your day-to-day it's going to go
into your cash account which is what you
can take out with the ATM so what
happens to most people is they'll spend
whatever money they have and it never
goes anywhere but if you're now
budgeting and saying well I'm just going
to put like 200 or 300 in my cash
account I can spend that but guess what
once you spent it you know it because
you can't take any money out that month
right and then you also set up a
checking account which is for things
like your like every single month
recurring things like your rent or like
your car payments and you know what that
you can predict that as well and the
whole goal is that knowing that those
are going to go off the next offramp
which means they're never going to go
anywhere provided all your money is just
going to those to you can never build
any wealth but even if you just start
with your first $10 extra which is what
Rockefeller did right it's what Bill
Gates did just $10 extra to go to the
second lane that's when you create your
investment account right and that
investment account just needs to be the
deposit account that's all it needs to
be so now we just got four accounts
we've just got the clearing account
which goes into a checking account and
which goes into a cash account and then
we just have and you can just do direct
debit so it just all gets organized
automatically the investment account is
you're going to your G your goal is
you're going to go from $10 a month
you're going to get it to $20 a month
which is already 100% increase right and
then up to $40 a month and it doesn't
take that long for it to start growing
and you won't even miss it going to the
investment account but once that
investment account gets to at least
$10,000 and it will get there faster
than you can imagine the moment you
start thinking this way from that middle
account then you start investing that in
assets you can invest it in property you
can invest it in a business you can
invest it in all sorts of different
asset classes which you'll get to learn
about as you're starting to go down this
pathway and every one of those third
lane cars that are now carrying your
money will return some of that cash to
you back in your investment account the
next month not into your clearing
account not for you to just go out and
spend on crazy stuff but into your
investment account and that's going to
over time start to create enough income
that it becomes passive income
eventually so you don't even have to
have the job anymore now the key to this
is not saying I've got to figure out how
to get out of my job first or I've got
to figure out passive income first no
you just got to figure out flow and if
you actually start organizing everything
into flow in this really simple easy way
already you're freed from the worry of
money from the very first week of doing
this the bank will do all this for free
right and they'll actually set it all up
and organize it all but the most
important thing to know is you can't
expect to grow your wealth if you're
putting it all into one big bucket and
then it's impossible to manage anymore
then a chef would never put all of the
food in one bucket and then think
they're somehow going to be able to
create a masterpiece from that one of
the words you used in introducing that
concept was respect and I think that's
something that people need to have
there's got to be a respect for money
right a respect for a discipline around
it which is what you just described
which I think is a great discipline um
and I guess the idea of keeping
recirculating your profits from the
investment account back into it starts
to compound it and that's how that
account AB abolutely does it it it
completely does and and and what you're
saying is so true like all money is an
energy just like anything and and it's
always going to go to wherever it's
going to be of most use uh if you don't
respect money itself if you don't
respect what you can do with it and you
don't respect how much people actually
care about it or May care about it uh
you're never going to be in position to
accumulate it and actually then use it
for good and so I think that that's
where a lot of people get it wrong is
that like can you can you imagine trying
to treat a person right without respect
trying to treat a person badly and then
expect that person to come back to you
why would money be any different makes
perfect sense this is a journey and you
have to be willing to understand there's
phases of this journey and you might
have this this Quest this this almost
lust to be a conductor you know but you
have to also embrace the fact that it's
a journey and it's great maybe you have
visions for some something positive in
the
future how should the journey from the
psychological level now how should it be
experienced what you know what what what
do people need to have in the way of of
resources uh you know mindfulness and
their own psychology what do they need
to have to do this journey cuz it's not
an easy Journey it's not an easy journey
I I'm a big fan of Kong because because
Kong like really codified a lot of the
things that I talk about within our
programs where we talk about change and
the Book of changes the ancient book of
changes the iching from China that was
published in the West for the first time
at K Yong and K yong's whole Focus was
on archetypes I didn't know that so so
Yung was the first one to published to
iching yeah yeah publish in so so what's
what's really interesting about that
whole story was that it was actually a
missionary who was out in um in China
who uh who founded iching and actually
was the one was the first to actually
you know like uh uh uh go through and
and and translate it into German brought
it back and actually met up with Kong
and then Kong basically was the first to
published it he published in the West in
about I think it was like 1920 and then
his book psychological types came out a
few years after that and all those
different ideas of like the different
energies of how we go about like you
know uh managing our our lives and our
um and our frequencies all turned into
words we know today in psychometric
testing like introvert extrovert and you
know intuitive sensory but all of that
like really comes back to the fact that
we have natural archetypes and someone
who took that one step further was
Joseph Campbell where Joseph Campbell
talks about the hero's journey hero's
journey and with the hero's journey the
interesting thing is these specific
phases that we go through the first one
of which is the court to Adventure being
even aware that when someone might be
speaking to you about a particular
opportunity that this could be the
turning point for your entire life right
and beginning of Adventure you know this
interview could be the very beginning of
someone listening to this and saying I
could just listen to this and go back to
my life or I could listen to this and
actually say this is a sign right I've
got enough of them and now here it is
it's time to take action I'm going to go
on the adventure and the moment you you
have that person notice the call has
been received and then decide to take it
they become the hero right from that
very moment the second part is the
interesting part second part is called
the road of Trials cu the road of Trials
is where everything gets thrown in your
way right to not to stop you but to test
you and the number of people that quit
at their second point cuz they're like
well obviously this was way too
difficult obviously it's not right for
me and they quit it as opposed to to say
wait I'm actually being tested at this
point to see if I'm worthy for the
journey and so the next time someone
goes on a journey and actually starts
noticing things are tough It's because
they're meant to be right but if you
actually go through that second phase
where things are tough and you're still
persevering through then you get to the
third phase which is the Boon which is
basically like the the reward uh and
it's where you actually get to a level
of success which which is because you
push through many people stop there as
well right but that's not the end for
the hero that's only halfway through the
Journey the the next part after that is
a return which is where you're going
back to wherever you got started from to
share that gift uh the reason we're
having so many people in the world today
who are entrepreneurs or people who are
successful share it is because they're
ongoing with that Journey knowing it's
not about what you're getting which is
important it's what you're giving become
a finder rather than a Seeker absolutely
right and so that next point which is
the return that's the point at which the
hero then is able to complete the
journey before starting off again and I
think that's such a powerful uh visual
for people to especially through the
dark times because you know anyone who's
got to success has had to have a lot of
sacrifice and have a lot um of times
when they had to kind of question
themselves as well uh but if you really
start noticing these stages it's far
easier to then navigate through and also
to be mentored through by the right
person who's also gone through that same
Journey well you know it's really
interesting because you said sometimes
they start again it's that that people
can say hey i' I've made the full
Journey but now I'm called to a new one
and it the whole thing starts all over
again oh yeah well there there's people
who've got multiple Journeys happening
at the same time right like I'll look at
all the different companies I have and
the different team members that I have
the partners I have and knowing every
one of them is going on the same journey
I mean who needs Netflix right when you
when youve got this real life Theater
which is the planet and you've got all
these incredible like stories that are
actually unfolding right in front of you
in real time uh that experience of of
knowing there's a world out there where
there are these real life Heroes every
day that you can actually get connected
in with and that want you to to be part
of their journey and they want to be
part of yours as well it becomes
something which really gets to the core
of what entrepreneur spirit is all about
so I've got to ask this you've got this
extraordinary well of energy and you
know we're just talking about things
that you're passionate about and it's
stream of Consciousness it's coming out
you've got models Frameworks you see how
it all works you've got you know uh you
know your your your purpose in it all um
and you obviously have a passion around
it but if if I were to ask the question
what drives you I mean you this is this
is really like strong passion and it's
it's not blind passion I mean it's very
well thought through but what is driving
all this where where where's this well
of of energy that you're that you're
tapping into that brings you to the
presence that you
have I had a really uh interesting
experience uh on my 50th birthday and I
had my birthday in Japan and there was a
whole group of us and we went to uh
Bonsai uh it was like a Bonsai Garden
Bonsai Museum these bonsai trees are
beautiful and we were having a tea
ceremony there and there was a woman who
was like I think it was like a Who would
know you can get a black belt in tea
making right but this woman was like a
seventh Dan tea maker and she was
spending like half an hour making the
tea and in the process of making the tea
uh she said do you know why we spend so
much time preparing the tea and
preparing the environment and we said
why is that and she says because of this
uh Japanese concept which she actually
showed us the painting of the of The
Words which is um Ichigo Ichi and she
says Ichigo Ichi means treasure every
meeting for it will never happen again
right this idea that like if you
actually really take the present and
realize that it actually is sitting in a
tiny little droplet of infinity and that
at every moment it has to be cherished
provided you're thinking of infinity as
well we walked out from there and there
was an old man who was actually there
clipping the bonsai trees and some of
the team got into conversation with him
and it turned out he was the owner of
the whole place right he was in his 70s
he uh he' made his money in ramen
noodles and he' put it all back into
this it's like $20 million worth of
bonsai trees there and he was there
working on it and we asked well how how
much do you work on these trees and he
goes oh I'll get here 6:00 in the
morning be here until like 6:00 or 7 at
night like 12 hours a day and we're like
well how long youve been doing that for
and he like my since my retirement last
20 years this is what I've been doing
and we said why would you work so hard
on these trees and he said because
because you don't understand these trees
outlive us all right he showed us the
tree this tree is a thousand years old
right that's like it's like 15
Generations from someone who died that
child grew up died another child grew up
died like 15 times that happened this
tree saw all of it and now I'm looking
after it and after me there will be
another 15 20 Generations that also will
be looking after this tree how could I
how could I not do what I'm doing
because if I stop I'll be letting down
everyone before me and everyone after me
as well and this this idea of thinking
outside of ourselves to a greater good
uh back to one of my mentors Buckman
Fuller he has on his Tombstone the words
call me trimtab and he explained trim
tab as the fact that if you take a
massive ship uh the ship in order to
move has got this tiny Rudder at the
back and You' think the rudder is the
thing that's making it move however they
found that if you put on the rudder
another Rudder which is called a trim
tab a teeny weeny little just slice of
metal and so when you actually are
moving the rudder this trim tab also
moves a little bit the boat actually
shifts double or triple as far just
through this tiny tiny little piece of
the ship Which is less than 00 1% of the
metal on the ship that's the power of an
individual the fact that he saw his
whole life as being something where he
could move move Humanity if he could do
that how could you not right I think for
me what drives me is I think of my great
great great grandchildren and I think
about them looking back in time because
they'll be look at Facebook archives and
things like that and they'll know that
what happened on the planet at this
critical moment right now when we're in
the final exam that during this time now
their great great great great
grandfather was alive and they'll be
asking well what did he do while he was
on this planet when he already knew
better and I think about that every day
because when you come with that sense of
mission you come with that sense of
absolute obligation that how could you
not do everything you can to make a
difference in the world that's what
drives me every single day and I for me
personally I feel that when you are
tapped into that much larger piece of of
humanity itself you you get to feel it
you get to experience it in a very
different way than than than just
thinking of yourself which I think for a
lot of us we do uh this is the
difference of of being a drop in the
ocean compared to being the entire ocean
in the drop so you seem extraordinarily
um passionate obviously you're I think
you're fulfilled by this this purpose
but your smile tells me you're happy
yeah I'm absolutely youy very happy yeah
and and happy happy in a way where um
where it's not a complacent happiness
there's a good friend of mine Lyn twist
who wrote a book called The Soul of
money and she came up with a really nice
phrase for this um she called it blessed
unrest she said that there's a part of
us where we need to live in Grace we
need to live in happiness we need to
live as if it's all complete so we're
not needing anything we have no chip on
our shoulder we have nothing to prove
but the unrest is still there that
they're still incomplete business and
and for us to come up every day in
absolute gratitude that it's all already
complete but with the power to realize
that the future can be so much greater
uh and so there's still more to be done
that that's how I show up every day and
it shows a little birdie has it that you
Journal yes I do so you obviously think
that it's a great practice I think it's
essential I think it's essential yes
yeah so tell me about your journaling
well okay first of all I think the
reason that it's essential is because
there is a number one skill set or key
muscle in the brain you have to have to
be successful entrepreneur which comes
back this idea of predictability and
it's vision and and the reason vision is
because we have two types of recall in
our mind we have backwards recall which
is called memory we have forward recall
which is called vision and the
difference of those two is everything
because if your memory is stronger than
your vision you're always going to be
stuck in your path inste past instead of
moving to your future uh if you if you
speak to any of the uh people out there
from the Nelson mandelas in the world
when he was out there saying I'm going
to change South Africa through you know
to the uh you know top uh entrepreneurs
today who are always when you meet with
them never talking about the past but
always talking about the future is they
have such a clear memory of the future
of where you're heading and how you're
getting there and so when we go to
school we're learning how to memorize uh
we never actually learn how to vision
and so when I am journaling what I'm
doing is I am creating visual memories
uh and I'm constantly journaling about
my future I'm constantly drawing out
what it looks like not just for myself
but also for the people around me for
the planet itself uh and so when I'm
drawing I'm opening up that visual part
of my brain and that's where all the
magic happens and comes full circle you
you start out as an entrepreneur drawing
yeah absolutely so that what is helpful
right that that off for my life this is
what this is what um has been the way
that I've opened myself up to bigger
thinking and in fact all the way through
school I would always be drawing in
class and to begin with I got to off for
doodling but when the when the teachers
started realizing it's actually how I
memorize and remember things uh then
they were actually quite happy for me to
continue wow so you verbally I think uh
created a great vision uh you know of
what the future could be by raising the
Consciousness and bring more
entrepreneurs into the world Etc I see
that you materially actually write these
things down which is which is really
awesome and uh it's exciting you know
just to hear about your Ventures the the
nature of what it really means to being
an entrepreneur um understanding the
phases of I mean you really have thought
about this for a long time is there any
other aspect that you'd like to share
about the spirit of of the entrepreneur
and and what it means to the future of
this planet I think one thing which I
got inspired by after realizing Buckman
fer had put out this whole world this
whole idea of like the final exam as as
the scary thing that we actually had to
pass as he also talked about this thing
called the world game right and the idea
of the world game was making a game that
was fun enough uh and that had clear
enough rules that everyone could play
and the idea that we could actually
change this planet and for the better
for all of us uh by playing the game
collectively I think we're living in a
world now where that's reality we you
have the United Nations that created the
17 United Nations Global goals in 2015
they've got a Target by 2013 of us
achieving those goals for everyone as an
entrepreneur to realize there's no
excuse anymore to not actually step up
and to do something which is truly
meaningful measurable that's going to
allow you to build your income and your
impact but it's all out there and
there's others already on that pathway
and they want to work with you as well I
think that that's one of the most
powerful messages for anyone watching
this is don't wait but actually get out
there and realize you have that spirit
inside yourself uh and that you can
actually allow yourself to just step
into that space and allow yourself to
grow I mean I have a story which is
probably one of the most impactful
stories uh that I've ever had about this
whole idea of the power we actually have
uh could I share the story yes please
yeah it actually came out of a chance
reading from my library in our Resort in
Bley so we have a library which is a
magical Library there's always more
books there because everyone who comes
always leaves their books for other
people and someone had left a book they
come back from India and they left a a
book which is a very obscure book that
someone else took I've never seen it
again but in there was a story of a
raindrop and the way The Story Goes is
this raindrop drops out of the sky and
it lands on this Jetty in the middle of
all this rain and it and as it gets to
the jetty it plops on the jetty and it
goes oh look I'm a rain drop WR never be
a rain drop before it's like this
fabulous and looks around with his
selfawareness of being a raindrop and it
sees there's other raindrops around as
well uh so it goes great there's other
raindrops this is very exciting I get to
be a rain drop for a while and it's just
looking at the other rain drops
experiencing separation and at the same
time experiencing The Human Condition
which is here I am but I'm
it looks and sees there other raindrops
which aren't even hitting the jetty
they're going straight into the ocean
and so it goes oh my gosh this is
terrible because they don't even get to
be rain drops and maybe one day I won't
be a rain drop and this experience of
living suddenly gets to the face of
death right like like I'm only here for
a while so as is contemplating that it
decid it decides it's going to try and
stay on the jetty for as long as it can
and then the wind comes and when the
wind comes some of the rain drops on the
jetty go flying off the jetty and it
realizes if I'm just staying here I'm in
big trouble I I better squash myself
down to be as small as possible so I
don't get blown off and it does what so
many of us do in life which is actually
just become as small a version of
ourselves as we can be and it does it
holding on and it's is doing that
feeling great about the fact it hasn't
actually dropped off at this point the
Sun comes out and it notices some of the
other raindrops that are holding on are
now evaporating and as they're
evaporating it really panics cuz it's
like if I stay here I'm going to
disappear and if I jump I'm going to
disappear whichever way it goes I'm
going to disappear and so as is thinking
well which one should I do it realizes
that it knows for certainty that by
staying here it definitely will be gone
whereas if it jumps it doesn't actually
know when it hits the water will it stay
as a raindrop or not so decides because
it just doesn't know it's going to make
that leap for me this is the whole story
of every individual who is safe where
they're at but realizes it's not the
final option and the idea of actually
taking that leap of faith and so it
decides out of the two it has to leap
and it builds up the courage and it
steps up and it gets caught by the wind
and it blows off the side of the jetty
and as it braces itself for landing in
the ocean it's actually happy to say
I've lived a good life i' be in a good
raindrop and whatever happens happens
but then when it hits the water the most
magical thing happens instead of the
Raindrop disappearing it actually
becomes the entire ocean yeah and for me
there's this power that I see every time
I see an entrepreneur who takes that
leap someone who's in a job someone uh
who was in school say I'm going to go
out there and I'm just going to risk it
I'm just going to see what I'm actually
capable of and for every person I've
seen who takes that step sometimes it's
not easy sometimes it takes longer than
others but for every one of them they
get into tapping into a much much larger
Spirit than themselves and they realized
that was the true self that they had all
along W well that's truly beautiful
truly beautiful story and metaphor for
what this is all about really people you
know think it's about money but this is
really what it's about absolutely so I
thank you so very much for just sharing
all that wisdom and for what you're
doing in the world thank you thanks R to
see the next episode in the money
revealed series check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there once you're using blockchain
without knowing that you're using
blockchain is when frankly the
opportunity is over yeah so right now
the more complicated it is for people
which is what I tell them the fact that
this is difficult and hard means that
there's an opportunity here